[Music]
all right
you want to flip
do you flip huh do you need a flip side
[Music]
you press a
what stage will they choose
yeah he's number one
all fighters will want to pick the
appropriate character for this match
look at them
we've gone for the same characters
good morning
get off my characters
oh good grab let's get it stop teasing
me bro keep your hands to yourself
[Music]
good one good one good one let's go
get off my character bro
so I was gonna Turtles
thank you
Max
unbelievably insane with a chance to
score a pig here this is where smart
meter management is going to come back
the trip
good judgment there buddy
[Music]
dude
it's not over yet
barely blocks
[Laughter]
what
immediate
he barely blocks the jungle cool big gap
between the two fighters
on top of the damages
[Music]
so cool
look at it
[Music]
get off
that grab the party songs
it's down to the wire here we go
okay
I don't know
I'm not feeling
sorry
are you sliding the FBC communities
oh yeah you're all you kids okay I got
it they pour the circle motions
flashlight
don't jump at me bro
it's a stun yeah
bull fighting foreign
[Music]
it's something
oh
my God
yo what is going on
all right can you can't come back on IOP
out there
would be a wild disrespectful in here he
tried to let him know
what happened
okay
real quick
[Music]
in the building what we doing are we
filming about that I'm gonna tell you
right now man on God and everything man
all this dude do is grab managers
so I haven't even looked like yeah yeah
for now
I Ain't No Lie well what I can say is
there's so many other little things that
they got going on
that it doesn't feel natural okay right
so like you know how people have a
different battles yeah it feels heavier
yeah
I want to be honest
ly
the controllers
or
okay
it's damn near ring zero yeah
yeah that's what we used to right we
weren't able to do none of that and I
saw him struggling with moves too so a
lot of stuff that was happening because
of they have fairies right they have
run-ups
yeah
and I didn't know I didn't know get out
of it
a bit but again it is
[Music]
I played my way right
um
it's coming Xbox this year so I gotta
worry about that language
so here first the Lord's Place three
five six for the first time
it actually literally
grab if you look at all the matches all
he did was
the process
bro I didn't get a chance to whip like
he's just skill off the cheese anyway it
doesn't make sense though it's a
PlayStation uh controller and it's
cheese available anyway moving along she
finally six you play to him it packs
debut you already know